but you know
the great thing about yesterday was we
had a lot of first-time submitters so i
think that's also a reflection
on our engagement uh program as well
angela as unfamiliar as you are with the
uh submission process
welcome along on behalf of arts matahiku
to the
hearing
previously you just make sure you get
that microphone up
she doesn't need a member well it's not
for her it's for the people on the
street
love technology kia ora good morning
everybody
angela newell i think i know quite a lot
of you so it's really nice to see some
familiar faces around
the table good morning your worship so
really i'm here today representing
atsumuruhku
the board of which i have joined in the
last few months
and really pretty much the submission
speaks for itself so
we'll take that as read really i'm just
here to kind of put a face to the
organisation i suppose um
representing a really great group of
people who have joined this trust
councillor emerson is obviously on it
too so
she knows a lot about it already and she
can certainly answer any questions that
you might have
at any other time we also have uh
councillor paul duffy
um mrs green neve from stewart island
uh emma carle uh who's got roots into
gore um blair
savoury who has massive productions who
has been
involved in getting events up and
running in the city
is myself michelle dawson who has done
extremely amazing work with
cs arts reaching out to members of the
disability community with her
organisation
and i think they said everybody and and
sally bodkin allen who's just joined
from sit so
it's a great group of people and we are
committed to advancing
arts and culture as much as we can
working particularly upon the
strategy that we had commissioned and is
here
now and in the in the submission we ask
that potentially
city council look at using this strategy
for guiding and informing anything that
you might be bringing up in terms of
arts and culture
in your work in the future so as i say
pretty much everything is in the
strategy at the moment um as in the
submission document so um really it was
just about any questions i i think that
i'm here for today
so far away thanks angela
councillors open to you for questions
uh thanks angela for the comments around
the development of hawakituya
um
do you want to uh expand a little on
arts marahiku's
support for the activities and and the
volume of activity there
yes so um obviously it's based on some
principles
of partnership um
collaboration sustainability so
it's all about finding ways in which the
arts can grow and develop
but also to be sustainable and of course
since covert we've seen a lot of changes
especially in people's attitude to the
arts and i noticed myself that the arts
seemed to
take over our screens and our lives in
many ways during covert during the
lockdown
and because we weren't able to go to a
lot of things during that time
i think now that everything is sort of
back up and running again
we're kind of enjoying that um so yeah i
guess it's
um hey wakati is as you know yet another
example of
the engagement that people want to have
in the community we had an
arts expo that you might have seen a
little bit of publicity about in the
weekend
and we had between 400 and 500 people
come through the doors to engage with
the 46 different artists
and organizations that were there
representing themselves
to engage with the public and it was
really successful and we had a great day
and
again i think everybody was reiterating
the fact that we really need this
connection with arts and culture we need
to be able to go to places where
arts are thriving and where artists can
connect with
with their audiences and you know it's a
little bit sad that we don't have the
arts festival now
and we don't have the buskers festival
and these two events that have sort of
fallen off the radar a little bit um you
know we these things need to be replaced
we can't just sort of
keep a vacuum you know there are always
got to be new things that are coming in
to
um you know replace what what may have
moved on or whatever for whatever
reasons so yeah yeah
the regional art strategy that arts
moloku developed
i understand it might have been before
your time on it but do you know how
widely the organization
um consulted in developing that uh yes
it was actually there's a list of all
the participants in the back of the
strategy
and um mary jane rivers who was tasked
with
um compiling this strategy made a huge
effort to get around as many places as
she could she she talked on phones she
met in person
and she really did her best to connect
with as many arts organisations as
possible so
we felt that that was a reasonably um
rigorous process that she went through
with that
course the arts are very connected in in
southland in terms of everybody knows
everybody else and
most people that are on one arts
organisation tend to be on
another or another you know so there's a
lot of cross-pollination of information
that happens even if you talk to one
person you're often covering
several different organizations or
genres
yeah councillor sopa
thanks mr chair um so angela we've had
quite a few submitters
talking about the museum and arts
and a lot of them are saying leave the
museum where it is
but have an arts presence in the center
city
and a few of them suggested that should
be the haiwakatuya premise
is that what the regional development
strategy would tend to agree with um
look
i'm not really sure that i can speak for
the strategy
identifying that as the way to go i
think there's still
obviously some work that needs to be
done in terms of determining
exactly where it is and i and i guess
you guys are tasked with that for
you know on behalf of of the city so i i
would just say that you've got to look
at what works
and what doesn't work and really focus
on the what works so if there are
elements
of you know keeping things at at the
queen's park current site
then you know by all means look at that
but obviously arts and culture doesn't
have to happen just in our building
and in fact you know there's been quite
a bit of outreach that's happened with
arts and culture you know away from
buildings
and i think that that's something that
also needs to be looked at as well where
else can it happen
you know not just in one building thank
you
further questions councillors
i should just point out that just prior
to the hearing starting this morning
councillor anderson did
declare of course that she has an
interest in uh arts modaku but ant
and angela touched on that but um
there is really no no conflict with with
the hearings process your worship
yes one of the most sort of visual
situation in the arts is the
murals going yeah are you involved in
that
no i'm not but i every time i see one it
makes my heart smile because
they often very much express what's
going on here and now and that's the
great thing about murals they are
ephemeral you know they're here
for a time and then they disappear so i
actually really
encourage council to you know support
murals wherever they may happen because
they kind of do reflect what's going on
here and now
with the issues that people feel that
they want to put on the walls um
so if you look at other cities
particularly dunedin
you know next door neighbor have got
incredible murals all over their city
and it's interesting to walk around or
drive around and see the mural so
i'm not personally involved with them
you worship but i certainly would
advocate that
any that murals are definitely something
that brighten up a city
so long as they are managed correctly
and that you know they've
they've got some sort of artistic um
kind of excellence
going on there so that it really stands
out as an
outstanding work yeah there's a big one
down on the corner that's quite striking
um bluff and riverton have also had um
significant mural projects
as well yeah and i guess that once the
buildings are
more stable and put up an invercargill
we'll hopefully see a lot more
going on yeah yeah love them
further questions counsellors if not
thanks for giving up the time to come
along this morning angela nice to see
you again
thanks everyone
uh our next speaker is not due till 9 20
and i think is joining us by zoom
is that right by phone
hi zoom uh now her submission doesn't
appear in board books but i think
there was some written material
distributed yesterday
i didn't get it
it was it was distributed yesterday yeah
she's coming in by phone right
right miss baker's going to be joining
us by phone so we'll just get her on the
line
okay
yesterday
[Music]
halloween speaking good morning miss
baker and vacation city council calling
how are you this morning
good how are you good it's daryn
speaking we've um
just uh you're our second speaker this
morning for our
long-term plan hearing
we have a copy of counsellors all have a
copy of
of your written submission so you're not
unfamiliar with the process um we have
10 minutes if you want to make sure that
you leave a bit of time for counsellors
to ask questions
at the other end that would be
appreciated but otherwise the floor is
yours
all right um i can't hear you very well
is there can you hear me very well yes
we can hear you very well
right okay um well thank you for letting
me
um present uh it's just very short my
submission um
like first of all i i just like to
say well done for your um
roadmap terminal documents for the long
term plan
i thought it was really well presented
and um you're our city with a heart
um motto is you know it's it's really
lovely
so so well done on that a lot to take in
of course
and and that information so i'd just
like to say um going on to my second
thing that you've got there is the
southland museum and art gallery i'd
just like to say yes
to your preferred option um
you know that pyramid art gallery is
iconic
and it's not only a wonderful place
for us it was a wonderful place for
people to get together
you know and socialize and um
also the surrounding areas you know with
your queen's park it's
just so gorgeous there and it's you know
it's the loft
to the um to the city at the moment but
in saying that
the art gallery downtown is really
awesome
um i had the honor of presenting
there last saturday as part of a
woman artists group i've presented some
of my poems and there were musicians and
stuff there
so well done to your council for
encouraging the arts and involving
everyone not just in the in the cargo
area but
throughout southland i really appreciate
that so thank you very much for that
you still hear me okay yes fine thank
you
great um so yeah and on that
um the street art around the cbd
it's a wonderful thing and
you've incorporated lots of different
you know organizations like
schools and individuals and
you know um i just think um it brightens
up
the town and there should be more street
art
and i have got a petition about that
more street art in rural areas
but you're doing such a good job um
encouraging that
i know it's not particularly your
council that's doing it
in the cargo central wasn't it was amy
well she's doing a really good job
and um again involving lots of people
um which is appreciated and you'll see
um i've incorporated um i've put a photo
of
my humble hero's poppy
with um the poem that i've just
presented at an anzac day service
for an rsa i've actually read that
out this year uh because we of course
didn't have anzac day last year so
to have my painting and um
the poem that i wrote um displayed in
invercargill
actually next to a painting of the
invical cenotaph um i just think that
your council is doing a really good job
in encouraging art so well done there
too
um another well done i'd like to say
well done for the new
signage regarding dog control at the
otakuni
uh reserve you'll see the attack photo
um i'd like to say thank you to darren
ludlow
and also the staff at um
the parks uh for getting this new
signage
um done and this other signage i think
was put up through in other areas so so
well done
for um for that um
unfortunately and you'll see by that
photo
that i've um one photo that i've sent
him
there is still a bit of a dog control
problem where people are not obeying
the rules and you'll see that dog
is also laid in the cbd area on a
footpath with a person riding a bike
which i don't believe is um legal anyway
to ride a bike on the footpath so it's
just to be aware that there are people
still not abiding by laws
regarding dog control and um
i know your counselor is trying its best
but
um yeah it's still it's still a problem
and
um throughout new zealand it's a problem
and i've got petitions at parliament
at the moment regarding dog bite
injuries
there were 12 406
dog bite injuries in new zealand
between 2000 and um in the 2020 year
so i've just got those from acc this
year so
yeah i'm still persevering was
advocating for a better dog control
uh not only just in southland but in new
zealand as a whole
and you will see that i have got
um letters of support one letter is from
the new zealand institute of animal
management
president and he um
has uh placed my dedication and
determination for advocating for better
dog
ownership and also supported
one of my petitions um better dog
control and safer dog control i should
say
so um yeah i i just wanted to
um you've got a petition there
that you can see um obligations of dog
owners
um and that's regarding the dog control
act 1996
so ensure that dog owners follow their
obligations
and i've been over this many times
before
but i think it's important just to
reiterate the fact
that um you know dog owners have to
you know take um responsibility for
their dogs and make
ensure that they don't affect other
people's lives because we all have
a right to enjoy our different
recreational lifestyles
and yeah dog owners love their dogs but
other people love their lifestyles as
well so yeah it's a matter of
um you know being with dolgon's being
more responsible i feel
some dog owners are really good and i
thank them for that
um yeah so that's about it really great
thanks mr speaker we uh appreciate your
submission
your positive feedback and your
continued vigilance counsellors are
there any
questions that you'd like to ask
no it looks like you get off the hook
wendy
oh well thank you have a lovely day and
keep up the good work thank you
thanks for your time bye all right thank
you
welcome along
you just want to make sure you've got
that microphone that's sitting on the
table there pointing in the general
direction of your face that would be
useful thanks
it may be small but it's very precious
it's okay
thank you for the chance to comment on
this icc long-term plan
i commend you on the many positive
aspects of this long-term plan
however i wish to stress that certain
parts of my the
of my written submission especially the
fact that the ltp needs to ensure
that all council policies are seen
through a climate change
lens as we look to the future of our
planet
we all have a part to play in ensuring
carbon emissions are reduced
dramatically
i'm especially committed to making the
city more environmentally sustainable
user friendly for cyclists and walkers
having more native biodiversity
being food resilient and i commend the
kai collective on picking up on those
initiatives having healthy warm homes
stopping the use of coal for thermal
heat in both homes and businesses
and protecting our built heritage
buildings along with waste reduction
and stopping methane gas production
taking our government's climate
emergency declaration very seriously and
acting much more urgently to reduce
carbon emissions must be the top focus
for this ltp
in the cargo city and environment
environs
as a member of south and forest and bird
i strongly believe
in their objectives crossing birds
strategic vision for the district which
ties into our national forest and bird
strategic objectives and main theme of
giving a voice to nature is climate
centred
in the cargo city is resilient to the
impacts of climate change
any activities or developments in the
region must actively
mitigate their contribution to climate
change
people understand the threat and urgency
of climate change
and are supported in climate change
practices
economy that supports nature the city's
local economy and nature
are interconnected healthy nature equals
a healthy economy
vibrant landscapes the district's
terrestrial native flora and florna
are protected and enhanced in urban and
rural areas
invercargill's landscapes are free from
pests
development can occur without clearing
and destroying landscapes and their
respective
ecosystems energized
water river rivers and wetlands
in the cargo's rivers streams and lakes
are clean
healthy and teeming with life especially
native species
wetlands are protected and enhanced
excuse me in the cargo under the climate
emergency declaration
city council has a priority to
sustainably manage the natural and
physical resources in the district to
meet the reasonably
foreseeable needs of future generations
safeguard the life-supporting capacity
of
air water soil and ecosystems
and avoid remedy or mitigate any adverse
effects of activities on the environment
it is essential that icc takes this
responsibility seriously
and looks at all its policies and
proposed plans through a climate change
lens
meaning they need to be protectors of
the natural ecosystems under their
jurisdiction
young people as future generations are
looking to all of us
as adults to take climate change
seriously
and not just look to our own wants and
needs often based on the economy
as a priority young people expect the
ltp
to focus on their interests and
livelihoods which are at stake
to lead the way to maintain the life
support and capacity of our ecosystems
and to drastically reduce the damage of
our current practices on the environment
icc must act consistently with these
moral and ethical values
and understandings when formulating this
plan
subsidies also need to be available to
move or fossil fuels for heating in both
homes and businesses
in particular coal not only is this a
major contributor to climate change
carbon emissions
but it also causes severe pollution
affecting the health of our invercargill
people
and decreasing hospital emissions
especially in winter
subsidies need to be provided to move in
cargo's q hospital off coal
as well encouraging central government
to provide
funds to do this support of three waters
investment
i support the proposed investment to
improve three waters infrastructure
as this will contribute towards
maintaining and enhancing fresh water
qualities
and supports their preferred option for
drinking water
council needs to support current efforts
by voluntary group
being made to improve the state of the
water quality of the invercargill
estuary
icc needs to change the rules around
vehicles on beaches especially
already beach tour recovery is being
very badly affected by vehicles and bad
behaviour by some drivers not being
responsible
waste production whilst carbon dioxide
is the bigger
biggest driver of long-term climate
change methane is far more potent in the
shorter term
warming the atmosphere more than 85
times as much as the same amount of
carbon dioxide does
over a 20 year period for this reason
every effort must be made to reduce
methane production
this must be done at the ic sewage
treatment plant with resources in the lt
plan to encourage this
as well ltp resources to deal with waste
from the city
needs to include not only reduction and
re use of resources
but also a green waste collection system
and food waste
recycling into composting systems so
this material does not go to the
landfill
and produce methane which is so
dangerous
support for parks and reserves and
places which keep our city inhabitants
healthy
i support the initiatives as listed in
the tuaki
ara flyer and especially making the city
centre a family-friendly space
with shade trees community seating and
play areas for children and teenagers
bluff needs special attention as it
raises its profile across
rte aurora no tororo
from your food basket and my food basket
is sufficient for everyone
iwaka ekino we are all in this wonka
together
rugby maria gilter thank you jenny
uh and thank you for a full and well
constructed uh submission
councillors it's open to uh for you to
questions now
lucky escape training thank you for your
that's also the sign of a
attention a submission that hasn't left
any questions unanswered
there's lots to do uh yes it's quite a
list
thank you very much and and appreciate
you coming along this morning
kim horena kim welcome along
good morning your warship and
councillors thank you very much for the
opportunity to appear before you today
my name's kim riley and i'm appearing
before you for federated farmers
south island province uh we acknowledge
the myriad challenges that councils are
facing around the country at the moment
both in light of the covert 19 pandemic
in particular for the city council
around the ty point transition
and we also acknowledge the volume of
central government regulation that is
being placed upon councils and then
you're having to work through how to
make that work in a local area
so we do appreciate those those
challenges that are before council
we appreciate you all have read our
submission uh so we'll simply highlight
a few matters that we have um draw
attention to within the submission
firstly while farmers are happy to pay
their fair share of the rating burden
we oppose the council's proposed changes
to the rating system that has come
through the long term plan
the changes proposed are unfair and they
disproportionately increase the burden
on rural rate payers
we note that sample property rural
properties have had no increase in
capital value
yet face up to a 17.8 per cent increase
in rates
while residential properties who have
had increases to set capital value
based closer to a three percent increase
the consultation document refers to
these changes as being to a simpler
system
in our view it is simply an unfair
system
we oppose proposals to move away from
the use of targeted rates
and we oppose any further reductions to
the farming differentials
federated farmers supports rating
systems that match those who benefit
from a service to those who pay
general rates capital value approaches
simply reflect the size or the value of
a property
with no direct correlation to those who
have relative benefit
from a given service we oppose the
proposals to halve the use of the
uniform annual general charge
this per property charge is the most
equitable means of allocating costs
it should remain at 360 this year an
increase to the maximum 30 percent of
eligible revenue
in each year following within the long
term plan
we note that council is proposing an
additional 112 million dollars on
capital projects over the next 10 years
and we question whether this is the time
to take on such ambitious nice-to-have
projects
and we note and agree with the
auditor-general's comments in this
regard
we further oppose these nice-to-haves
being disproportionately funded by rural
ratepayers
particularly when they won't have that
same access or delivery of services
as those in urban areas we find the
consultation documents use of average
rates increases for each proposed
project a bit disingenuous in this
regard
uh given the greater impact that will
fall on rural ratepayers
as proposed by council farmers are
ultimately paying considerably more than
urban ratepayers
for the city's footpaths street lights
buses and economic development
in short we consider that changes
proposed to the council's rating systems
may be simpler but they are not fair
simpler is not better if it is unjust
and unjustified
council needs councils across the
country need to stop seeing farmers as
the district's easy money
expected to disproportionately fund a
wish list of projects
we seek that council retains its
existing rating system
we seek no further reduction in the use
of the uniform annual general charge
or rural resident rural differentials
we would like to see council cap its
rates rises to no more than the local
government cost index unless it is
funding growth
and we support but we support council
maintaining dog registrations at the 35
for working dogs with the maximum number
of dogs charged remaining at five
um that's pretty much the highlights of
our or low lights i guess is how you
look at it of our submission but
we're just drawing attention to across
the country we submit to all
long-term plans and we're finding this
year a really big struggle with
quite considerable rates rises coming at
farmers
when at the same time they're struggling
with multiple
new regulatory pressures on the farming
system
and similar struggles in light of covert
and access to
to employees and and other um issues so
just highlighting the wind councils put
out an average rates increase
the general impact on farmers is a lot
higher and
and we prefer the existing rating system
to what's been proposed
thank you for that under the existing
rating system i
don't think your members um contribute
towards things like
um street lighting and some of the
things are
looking at being shifted across and yet
when when they visit
the city as a service center they do
receive the benefit of them so do you
not feel it's fair that they contribute
to that in some way
yes but when that's funded through
general rates per
the the additional cost on farmers is a
lot higher than the urban
ratepayer so because of the per property
value
so they're paying disproportionately
more than the urban and happy to pay
their fair share for those things you've
highlighted
but it's just when you're having a
general rate based on capital value the
impact is
is higher they currently enjoy a
differential
and even though there is still a
differential proposed it is it has
reduced one that's still a benefit not
uh the the average ratepayer doesn't get
in order
the average rate they have the
opportunity to claim back gst on a lot
of their expenses
yeah but when you look at the average
increase for a farmer's rates bill when
your sample properties they are
considerably higher than
an urban rate payer so we just are
asking for some equity
between what urban rate payers are
facing and what the rural ratepayers are
facing and acknowledge the use of the
rural differential and we
and we appreciate that but when you are
looking at a system largely funded on
on general rates then um it does end up
being disproportionately unfair targeted
rates we support we
support the use of the uniform annual
general charge we support the use of
targeted rates that ensures those who
benefit from a service or a relative
benefit
such as a street light and matters
you've referred to
it it does come a more equitable way
than general rates and
and um as a general philosophy we just
think general rates end up
putting a higher burden on the valuable
size of property versus
the benefit that is received from those
matters
can i just clarify with you when you say
equitable do you mean
percentage-wise or in dollar value well
when you look at the sample properties
this year i think you can see that
i think the gen the um the rural
residential properties were facing
around a um 85 dollar
to up to a high value property 600
increase in their rates bill this year
um farming
up to three thousand dollars in the
sample property rates bills which is a
you know up to a seventeen point eight
percent so we're we're just
acknowledging that if everyone's
receiving similar levels of service on
some of these matters that it is a more
equitable
and the existing rating system we do
believe reflects that
um with a rural residential uh rural
differential
in play that that reflects the fact that
it's not the value of a property that
equates to an ability to pay all the
service received from that
so we support this yeah federated
farmers understand we don't have poll
tax as an option though we don't have
wealth taxes an option for rates
yes yeah we do and we acknowledge the
struggles that councils are facing
across the country and it's not an easy
task and we certainly acknowledge that
we're just
asking for a bit more consideration
across the country certainly not just
this country but the council where
we're flagging that across we've had you
know up to 50 rates increases in some
districts for farmers and it is becoming
an increasing pressure
and well-being is a real issue out there
at the moment so we're just flagging to
councils just to keep that top of mind
thanks kim i'm i'm not meaning to i
don't know i'll wind you up once
not at all wound up completely
appreciate the question thank you
councillor pottinger
oh thank you um my question is uh
how many commercial yeah just looking at
the
fiscal size of the yuma cargo city
boundary yeah how many commercial
farming units
are there i mean you know there are
proper farms not
it's not as high as other districts i
wouldn't have the exact number off the
top of my head i could
i could get that but it is lower but
it's still those for those individuals
there is the impact
okay uh what percentage of those units
then are dairy farmers
i wouldn't be able to tell you the
percentage size no that's okay i just
had some questions around that
i hope you that's okay thank you
thank you councillors any further
questions
thank you kim as always it's uh it's a
full and well constructed submission
that we receive from federated farmers
so thank you for that
thank you for coming along thank you
everyone
june welcome along
they're just giving out um another copy
of my amended submission
because i've done a bit of that about
face
okay
you thank you
thanks jane the floor is yours i needed
submission to the long term plan
your worship and city councillors
atamari
kojo naho no waihope
first of all i wish to thank you for the
opportunity to give feedback
on the long-term plan you have in front
of you on your computer's my
first submission to the long term plan
and i did practice the speech for it
um but in the meantime i rang russell
pearson just to ask about
how don street would look as a two-way
street
which i was opposed to initially because
i thought it
would detract from the special character
of don street it's my favorite street
it's got two art galleries um it's got
historic building of the invercargill
club it's got
herakitoria and cafes
and it's also more sheltered than
other streets in the cbd so
for me it um i was
worried that it would be um
two-way street would destroy some of
that
so anyway i rang russell and left the mr
asking him to ring me
i wanted to know why the two-way don's
street proposal was being
put forward when he rang me back he
answered my queries and clarified what
the street would be like under the
proposal
i have been reassured that don street's
special character would be
enhanced and not detracted from i'm very
grateful for his time
and detailed explanations don street is
my favorite street on the zbd and it's
complimented by herokutoria
the museum transitional museum i am
enjoying the close proximity of its
excellent exhibitions
the current one which includes life-size
photographs of family groups and nurses
in the era of world war one it's
fantastic exhibition
but i would still like to be able to
soon return to the gala street south and
museum and art gallery
i wish to acknowledge the dedicated work
of museum staff
at prison we have the wall gallery and
the sit down street building
and the pop-up art athletic gallery
upstairs and tay street above bollings
in the interest of continuing art and
culture and the cbd
it will be necessary to support this
vital aspect of our community's
well-being
lastly i would like to emphasize that
wagner place
does have an important function of
offering open
uncluttered public space within our city
of building construction
and roadworks also with their borders
being gradually opened overseas visitors
will become more frequent
but please bring back the eyesight i've
met several visitors looking very
bewildered
looking for the eyesight in rockner
place it's embarrassing
to say to them well we actually don't
have an eyesight now
we are trying to promote our city we
need our eyesight back again please
thank you for your time and attention
thanks gen we appreciate your
amended submission and additional
comments we actually discussed
the the issue around don street was the
subject of an uh extraordinary
infrastructural services committee
meeting yesterday so
russell's been very busy around that and
and we're grateful that he uh took the
time to write yes i
really did appreciate um his time
because i thought it would just be
five minutes but it was longer than that
the phone call so i do
appreciate his time good thank you for
that feedback counselors
it's over here for questions
counselor clark thank you chair
june just one question around the
eyesight um
as we look to do some development of the
museum in the future and if one of the
options we look at is to
um redevelop the museum back where it
currently is
um and the office and then and the cbd
no no all right nagala street
yeah sorry we used to have the eyesight
there
um and what's your view on that is that
the ideal placing for it or should
the eyesight be separate i don't know
i'm sorry
it's a tricky one isn't it i think i i
like
it in the cbd and what the place because
you get all the
buses stopping outside tortara
and it's a natural place for people to
get off the bus
and then walk over to the eyesight and
um conversely at when it was at
gala street um
yeah there was a lot of young people who
didn't have
transport so much to get there
whereas i think maybe it's easier to get
to the cbd in the eyesight but it's hard
one
maybe we need it in both places well
i mean we need the museum and a little
museum in the cbd
and also in carla street
yes because that that's part of the
feedback i get is that
maybe the eye sight should be in the cbd
somewhere
but then the flip side of that is the
eyesight did support the
cafe that was in the museum as well yes
yes please okay thank you we're diving
into comments there
thank you uh councillors any further
questions for june
if not thank you very much for coming
along and speaking to your submission we
appreciate it
mr tudor you've actually arrived just in
the nick of time even though we are
running ahead of time if you'd like to
come up and and take a seat welcome
along
thank you thank you for this opportunity
come on address the council
the mayor mr schedule
let's go get my special tool
um so i presume i'll just you've got uh
you've got ten minutes we'll ring a bell
at five um but if you want to make sure
that you've left some time
for the councillors to ask some
questions but the floor is yours
thank you um basically i like your plan
but my only concern is perhaps it should
be a 15-year plan
not the 10-year plan i think that the um
if it was stretched out perhaps it might
be a wee bit easier on the rate payers
in the level of rates
but i've got no financial information to
suggest that but that's just just
my concern um
and then just looking down the thing
while we're concerned with the rates is
the fact that
there's a lot of people in vocabulary on
fixed incomes
like superannuation things like that so
having a five percent then another four
and four and four it's it's quite
daunting when you look at the whole
picture over the long
period so we need to consider that but
then when we start to look down your
roadmap
um one of the things that comes to my
mind museum and art gallery while i know
the museum should have been gone with a
long time ago
then we've got anderson's park
that was our art gallery i believe so i
might be corrected on that
but we've also got further down your
roadmap something else about arts and
creativity are they not
three things that are pretty closely
related and
could be brought under the same thing uh
sorry park world favorite
mr skelt parking and access that's your
problem also all the time you know about
that
um but if we're expanding things at
surrey park
um quite frankly i think the stadium
needs the footprint for isn't it frozen
in time it shouldn't
be growing and if there's something else
needed perhaps we need another
standalone building down there
perhaps we're badminton basketball and
in that corner of the old school
area that's of gymnastics and various
other people need
constructions in the future um
as rape powers we spend a lot of money
on the civic theater and it's a
really nice heritage building
is it being utilized enough
for what was spent on it versus events
that are being held elsewhere in the
city
and i know the stadium markets to get
events down there
but perhaps some of those events should
have been actually at the civic theatre
and making better use of what we've paid
for there
and the strengthening and modernisation
um
just our rates are 13 increase on our
5000 square meters at atari
people don't understand what rates
and how they're calculated they look at
an installment
of the right account which shows none of
the nitty-gritty
or individual proportions of the rates
and they're publicly saying on facebook
that um they're paying similar rates to
town
and they're not getting the services so
they don't understand that
those of us who have lived there for a
day or two understand it pretty well
from when we were brought into the city
from the south and county
the reason they're they're paying
similar rates to town they're looking at
the bottom line
and they're locked onto four thousand
square meter lot sizes so the land
values are higher
but the amount of rates they're paying
dollar value is similar to town
if you want to have garbage collection
out there off bonds it's another 265
a year and that is not on your rates
that is actually an extra payment that
you have to make over and above your
rates
some areas about a tara the four
thousand square meter lot sizes
and and that was set up under the
southland county
there was no surge in other tower at
that stage and they were concerned about
surge pollution and property and lot
sizes
and that's rightfully done we had surge
in the ditches
we don't have surge in the ditches now
in most areas because it's serviced by
sewage so why are we still locked into
the 4000 square meter lot sizes
it costs the city millions of dollars to
expand infrastructure
yet we've got these pockets of land that
could actually have more houses on them
without affecting um the amenity values
and if they've got native bush on the
property like we have
that's fine don't go near it lock up
that piece of the property but
there are properties that are just
barren 4000 square meter sections that
perhaps could have another house or two
on the mountain
and that would be something that i'd be
a bit concerned about but there needs to
be some education and as to how
rates work for people out there
because if
they start having to pay for a lot of
the other services over and above on the
top
their rates bills will go proportionally
quite quickly
and be a lot larger let's make but i do
like your plan
thank you and thank you for the feedback
counselors
questions
one of the questions um around
the increase in and some charges for
services that might not have been
previously paid for
um street lighting footpaths and the
like uh do you think it is fair that
because odata residents receive the
benefit of those services when they come
into town
which is you know the same for me as a
town dweller i don't use the footpath
outside my house but i do use them when
i come into town
do you think it's fair that they should
contribute
for those services to a slight extent
yes
but so do winton people when they come
to town to work every day
and they don't contribute anything um
i understand odata pace for street
lighting i think that was still in it
when we were brought into the city
because we went item by item
away back then and that that was a long
time ago but i understand that atari
does pay for street lighting now
um and we should pay for some of it but
i'm just not quite sure we don't
how many people use the footpath outside
the house anyhow
there should be something there thank
you
councillors
no questions a light escape thank you
very much mr tudor for making a
submission and uh coming along and
speaking ahead of time as well
no that's right thank you councillors we
are running ahead of time
um annika's not due to speak until 10
past
10 so i will call an adjournment form
for 10 minutes please don't
go too far away but feel free to have a
have a stretch for a few minutes
you're so cute
okay welcome along uh thank you for your
submission councils have
had a chance to read through it we've
got 10 minutes um
we'll give you a ballot five uh if you
want to go for ten that's fine it just
it lessens the opportunity for
councillors to be able to to ask
questions
but but thank you for your submission
and essentially the floor is yours
okay um if you can just make sure you
pull that microphone in here i've got a
printer so i'm reading off my phone
so um bear with me honorable meres and
councillors
thank you for the opportunity to speak
to you today my name is uncle hebgood my
husband and i have four children
and i have with me our youngest daughter
francisca who is two years old
our family lives in the morris bush area
i saw the road map to renewal in the
southland express last week
and my submission is based on the
information in the consultation document
i understand there's more detailed
information available online but i've
had not
not had a chance to locate it and delve
into it further
going by media reporting on submissions
my first point in my submission is one i
have in common with many other
submitters
that my family would like to see the
council progress the renovation and
reopening of the southside museum and
art gallery far more urgently
than is currently planned my two older
children were seven
and four years old when the museum
closed we used to visit the museum
regularly
every school holidays and whenever there
was an interesting exhibition
that had just opened or an interesting
event on
if the museum is not opened until 2026
then they will
be potentially 16 and 13 years old when
it is reopened
i wonder will they still be interested
in family trips to the museum
at that age who knows what kind of
teenage
teenagers they will be but essentially
my two older children and other local
children
children their age will have been the
ones to pay the cost of this project
taking far too long as they are missing
out on the opportunity
during this their formative years
during the last school holidays my
children asked me as they often do
can we go to a museum well currently the
options in invercargill
paying to go to transport world or
motorcycle mecca
they're great attractions but with four
children that's not something we do
very often traveling to riverton or
dunedin but again it's not something we
do regularly
instead last holidays i took my children
to demolition world
as their museum experience to be fair
they had a ball it is quite an amazing
place to explore but really the fact
that we went to demolition world for a
museum experience
is also an indication of how much we are
missing the southern museum and art
gallery
my two older children and i were there
when the museum closed
suddenly it was an emotional closure for
us and many others as well given the
circumstances
but it appears it was not a new issue
issue for council back then
and now more than three years later we
are concerned that
we're no further ahead so we're
concerned that it's taking so long and
would like council to reconsider and
reprioritise this project
so that progress can be made on it more
urgently
so while i decided to submit on this i
briefly also made another couple of
points in my submission
the second was regarding rugby park
which is really again to support
my comments regarding the museum that
while it's important to upgrade rugby
park our preference is to see the museum
completed as a high priority the point
probably also applies
to other suggested projects like the
urban play for example which i didn't
specifically submit on
as i did not get enough of an
understanding from the consultation
document
but again i can come back to the fact
that i'd like to see the museum
higher prior prioritized more highly
my third point is a new one this is
something i've often mulled over
that the cycle network in invercargill
is piecemeal and we'd like to see
council take a bigger picture approach
to develop a full
safe cycling network in invercargill and
surrounding areas
there are existing tracks such as the
waihopa flood bank but from where we
live we need to drive to an entry point
to this track to make use of it
as the roads in our area are not that
safe for children to cycle on
mostly due to the speed of their traffic
so ideally we'd like council to look at
connecting up existing cycle roads
existing cycleways with smaller roads
that are safe for cycling
or in some limited cases when there are
no other options create cycle lanes
on those larger roads just long enough
to connect back up with smaller roads
i listed some ideas on my submission of
where investment could start but in a
nutshell
extend the waihopa flood bank track all
the way to mill road north
create a cycle lane along mill road
north bainfield road and
mciver road connecting back into the
flood bank tracks as well as donovan
park
extending the track along the odapune
towards mill road south and then
a cycle lane along will road south to
begin forming a cycle ring around
invercargill
extending the kingsworld track along
voxel street towards rockdale road
these are just a few ideas i'm sure if
someone properly studied a map of cycle
tracks in invercargill they could
potentially look at how the whole lot
could link up and give people safe
cycling options throughout
and around the whole city i think odata
is quite well catered for
in the sense that they've got the access
past the airport
it's more this side of town that i'd
like to see that linked up better
the aim should be to link existing
tracks up linking facilities parks green
spaces in schools
as well as other communities facilities
invercargill has a beautiful
black gently rolling country that is
perfect for cycling but it is important
to ensure that these are safe
to empower more people to get out there
and enable our children to grow up with
alternative transport options
my final point is my family's request to
council to look at
at the bigger picture and position
itself as a visionary leader on climate
change
this is also not a new issue and i don't
think i need to say much more than to
query what is council doing
to be a community leader on this issue i
don't have the answers but we would like
to see council provide leadership to
ensure our communities are able to
be to communities are able to do their
bit to reduce their impact and minimise
climate change
this is important again for the sake of
our children
thanks for your time today listening to
these few points that i've made and i'm
happy to answer any questions that you
might have
about my views thank you anka and thank
you for
sharing your your concerns and
frustrations around the museum
and the other places you visited have
you checked out the bluff maritime
museum oh yes definitely that's another
place where
we do go and that's an awesome wing
museum too good thank you
councillors it's open to uh questions if
you have any
councillor scout thank you just for you
um alec did you have any thoughts about
the actual
site of the museum in the sense of
currently we have the pyramid obviously
do you have any um thoughts about the
where it may be positioned going forward
we like the pyramid
and we think the location is great in
queens park it's always been really
accessible
um for our family and also when we've
had visitors from overseas
um it's the quickest and and
most efficient option to go with the
pyramid then that's
definitely the way we should be going if
it's going to take
even longer to go and research more
different places and different sites and
things like that
i'd i'd much rather see council get on
with it and get the pyramid up and
running again
thank you councillor pottinger along the
same lines and has councillor scott
what would you prefer and and this is
just a question to sort of
sound out whether building new or doing
up what we have
because obviously if we do it what we
have we can do that quicker
and that satisfies the now if we do it
new
and inspirational and that is something
for
that'll last 50 odd years which is more
important
satisfying than now or something
sometimes a council has to make a
decision that goes further into the
future
i think i don't see why you can't do
both i think you need to satisfy the now
uh and at the same time be planning for
the future i don't see how they
are like one or the other oh i'm just
saying if we went new
like yep new would take longer just
because of design
everything like that funding as opposed
to
what we have in the ltp so from my
understanding the problem
that why we're in this situation is
because he wasn't planning for the
future to start with
so we need to be um organizing
do you want to say something
there's nothing wrong with the
fascination and audio
that it wasn't a new issue when the
museum closed and that if there had been
a bit more planning and force taught
thought we wouldn't be in this situation
you you do realize just that there was
an ownership
um sort of debate you were
did you realize that it changed hands
the ownership
yeah the ownership of the museum was
owned by the um
smack board and then just recently it's
gone to council council never owned it
so did you realize that actually if i
can correct you their council always
owned it
i always owned it i'm sorry
the museum thought it owned the building
yeah
so i don't know how that's relevant i'm
i'm just a joey blog submitter and
that's something that council can sort
out i'm sure you've got the expertise to
work out ownership
and to work out how to get things done
it's just a matter of getting on with it
please
okay i love the practicality thanks um
councillor craic
my questions are about um i appreciate
your comments that you didn't feel like
there was enough
enough that was substantive in our
consultation document around the play
and what that play in the city could
look like
um but i wondered if you'd been to the
likes of the margaret mahi playground in
christchurch no i haven't been to the
margaret maher playground in
christchurch i saw that reference and i
did intend to look it up to see what
that was about
but i it wasn't the focus of my
submission and within the last few days
i didn't get a chance to delve into it
further that's okay the
idea of play within the city i mean i
love the idea
um get on with planning for it be
visionary
um it's just not everything can be done
now yeah so
if it's if it's something from what i
could gather if it's something that's
going to
sideline the museum then i think we need
to get on with the museum first
first priority yeah thank you and then
also get on with the vision as well
yeah of course okay cool thank you
thank you council is any further
questions
if not thank you very much for for
making your submission and for making
the time to come in and speak to it this
morning
all of those questions were about the
museum pretty much was there anything
into
terms of cycle tracks around
invercargill because i think that's also
the chair of cycle south has a question
for you
well a kind of question um
are you aware that there's um an
innovative streets project on at the
moment that is converting
uh divon street this um weekend
from saturday to into um to trial
what um arterial
cycle lanes in the inner city streets
will be like
and there is a constant effort to try to
connect a lot more
of those those cycle tracks around the
city yeah i'm
aware of the devin street project i just
saw that as
an isolation that's part of a bigger
picture project that will connect
so devon strength street for example
could link all the way through to connor
street to link up south city and then
like i said kingswool down ouch towards
the morris bush area again
and starting to link up looking at how
that can all link up the city can link
up as a whole that would be amazing
but if it's devon street in isolation
just to
have a little trial then i think you're
missing the point okay cool
so just on the the uh the circuit that
you talked about do you envisage that
that would
link up with the boardwalk down at the
estuary as well
yeah absolutely yep looking at all those
existing tracks and i know some of them
are
like the i hope i flood bank i think
that's what environment south and let's
put that together and things like that
again it's about council working with
those other agencies but
um taking the leadership to look at
where those bits
of cycle track are how they can connect
and
yeah where the schools are and could
potentially connect in with that as well
and there are lots of people that cycle
love cycling out the morris bush area
lots of adults that do that as fitness
and health and fitness and things
it would be great to be able to see
families getting out there and doing
that too so that we're able to get our
children
cycling in those areas from a young age
it's not until that you know at the
moment it's kind of like until you're
big enough before you can
cycle safely down finley road to get
from morris bush
to town and yeah my i could
let a 16 year old go but i don't think i
could let a 12 year old go and do that
no and i think we recognize some of the
key arterial routes around town aren't
currently safe for cyclists either
adults let alone
um yeah teenagers let alone children
yeah so those cycling
those connections like there's lots of
smaller roads that
um between finley road there's that we
gravel road that links up to the
flood bank track again i mean that's a
neat way road to to ride down but it's a
matter of connecting that up with
with the main road again so that we've
got minimal main roads and as maximal
possible
smaller connecting routes and ideally
cycling tracks
as per as much as possible okay thank
you very much for your submission and
for coming along this morning we
appreciate your time appreciate it too
our counselors i don't think jeanette is
here
as yet uh so i think i'll actually call
our
morning break early and we may come back
just a couple of minutes
um we were due to reconvene at
22 11 we might
uh if if jeanette turns out we might
make that
25 to 11. i know i can't believe that
thank you we're adjourned yeah
welcome along if you'd like to take a
seat please
thank you for your submission thank you
very much time to make a submission
it's working right now just yep that's
no it's fine it's fine now
it's fine okay uh i'll keep you to the
point
uh well first of all of all these
projects
that are very costly this is uh
particularly the museum
but there are other projects that are
costly uh the water tower anderson sport
and so forth
uh this this is very expensive if some
of these
proceed the rates will increase very
very much
um most people in invercargill
are employed in the alliance blue sky
meets
and ty 800 and ty 150 contractors at t
y pardon me
uh right so those things are on my mind
particularly uh
right how can the local people afford
that's the majority of the local people
in the cargo because
just as i mentioned before where they
work the majority of people
how can they afford their rate increases
if these projects go ahead
because the increases to rates will be
huge
very huge uh you need to look outside
the square the bigger picture
it's very important there's still flight
effects from the
october 19 of people losing businesses
and
so forth and also to mention a large
portion of people employed under ilt
and they have part-time jobs and they
don't earn much so it's so important it
really comes and presses on my mind
um the bigger picture you need to look
at that uh
the people of invercargill uh
the ti smelter project which closes in
december 24
will have a very major impact on
southland's economy
a very major there's nothing in place
the transition stage and
what will happen and if indeed it does
and if it does
what will it be and also the
invercargill jobs uh t-wise smelters
unpacked
uh have a flow-on effect
a lot of people would uh thin for cargo
myself and are really
really concerned for them all um
how can they afford to pay the rates if
they were to increase if all these
projects going ahead
a lot of people will be out of work as a
result of t.y smelter
but just the bigger picture all those
majority people employing those sectors
of work
they can't afford big increases in rates
and a lot of
families are struggling now and these
are my thoughts
and i would like to see something down
for the
youth of the cargo perhaps i'm not sure
what it could be but to keep the youth
off the streets
um but those are my concerns i'm very
very concerned of the
big rate increases thank you
some of these projects were to go ahead
and they're very expensive
and also it's um it's 2021 to 24.
so i'm looking you know still smaller
closes december 24.
thank you uh and points that we're
acutely aware of and
we share your concern about rates
increases
thank you for your feedback about stuff
for the youth and it's something that
they also
engage with us and regularly it was
interesting last year
i think we had a submission from them
during a project where
they were looking for activities but
essentially stuff that the private
sector provides but they wanted them for
free
but we are always open to hearing what
it is that they are
they are interested in and council
helping to provide for them
councillors do you have any questions
for for jeanette
on on her submission
councillor anderson thanks mr chair um
just wondering if uh if we were just to
pick one project
out of the the four projects that were
in the ltp
um so the city center urban play the
museum rugby park
which one do you think should be the
priority if i'd like to see the urban
don street thing go ahead
sorry
okay thank you well thank you very much
for your time thanks janine
thanks good morning bridget
welcome along your arrival perfectly
timed
it's because i tried to get her earlier
than that
this time i wasn't like super late it's
not your birthday this time though it's
not my birthday this time
thankfully i'm glad none of you knew
that that time
i think it was your first day on the job
too wasn't it it wasn't my first day on
the job
road kia ora culture
core bridget forsyth kyoto i'm bridget
forsythe and i'm the
southland health promoter for the otago
southland kent society
thank you for the opportunity to submit
on your long-term plan
as you can see the recommendations for
like each issue is pretty similar we in
general support your preferred options
but we want to see shade smoke-free
signs restriction of harmful commodity
marketing
and water fountains or bottle refill
stations incorporated into the designs
there are always costs associated with
prevention
but the benefits of preventing people
getting cancer far
outweigh the costs of things like
signage and trees which have many
benefits to other people as well
we have the highest rates of melanoma in
the southern dhb
and the highest incidence and death
rates of bowel cancer in the country i
really want to
remind you that these are not just
statistics
they're they're our people in our
community our families our colleagues
our friends so in terms of shade
the cancer society recommends increasing
shade in playgrounds and picnic areas
and
new developments skin cancer is
currently new zealand's
most commonly diagnosed cancer despite
being 90
preventable the southern region has the
highest incidence of
melanoma in the dhb uh in new zealand
sorry
compared with other territorial local
authorities invicable city ranks in the
bottom quintile
with the worst shade provision in
playgrounds
our surrounding neighbours are both
doing a bit better with gore and
southland both ranking in the second
quartile
however they don't get off that lightly
because even our top quartile
ranks considerably lower than our
australian ones despite having us
us having similar cancer rates skin
cancer rates to australia
the council can society recommends the
council invest in providing trees
or belt shade and near place spaces
planting trees provides green spaces
making the city
a nicer place to live supporting our
mental well-being
and benefits the environment by reducing
carbon dioxide and erosion
trees are a low-cost way to provide
shade and offer
a long-term solution however it's
important to design shade well
not all shade reduces uv effectively it
needs to both reduce uv
but still stay warm because if shade is
too cold people won't use it
so consideration into planting plants
by doing things like planting two or
three deciduous trees close together so
that their canopies
are touching to provide adequate shade
one day i'll be like so calm when i do
this i won't break a sweat
i promise but maybe that will be like 20
years from now
okay smoke free vapory signs so
we want smoke free and vapory signs
visible and in good condition in all
parks playgrounds sports fields and any
new developments
tobacco is still a leading cause of
cancer death in new zealand
killing more people than road crashes
suicide alcohol other drugs murder and
drowning combined
and that is tobacco companies kill
approximately 5 000 people each year in
new zealand which is 13 people a day
or 13.7 if you want to be
pecky whereas those other causes are
estimated to come to about 2154
people per year even if you take the
year where we had our deadliest
earthquake the 2011 christchurch
earthquake that only brings it up to
3337.
so you can see that tobacco is like by
far outweighing
all of those other harms and so it's
something we really need to work on
as of the last center census the
percentage of people who smoke in in
bakargo city was 17.9
which is higher than southland at 15.3
and higher than new zealand which is
13.2 percent and of course some
demographics have found it harder to
stop smoking than others
so as a council you can do more to
support people just
stop smoking and make it young people
less likely to start smoking
having clear smoke-free vapory signs in
all playgrounds picnic areas
and the new developments including the
city centre master play and the urban
place space
the southland museum and art gallery and
rugby park will be one way to do this
however i do really want to congratulate
you for the work you've done on your
smok free policy so far
you're a leading in the country one of
the leaders in the country
so by reviewing it in 2020 and combining
the 2017 smoke free areas policy and the
2010
smoke free parks and reserves policy
into one you've made for a really clear
succinct policy which is easy to
understand to public and staff alike
and we also really commend you for
including this vapefree in this policy
as well
as you'll know vapes products are now
included in this micro environments act
as of november last year so this has
really demonstrated clear leadership and
recognition
recognition that vaping is not safe for
people who do not smoke and not
something we want children and young
people to see as normal behaviour
but again i say we do recommend
is that a sign i have to really hurry up
well it just depends on how many
questions you want to feel but
please carry on bridgette okay i'll try
to race um
yeah so there's strong public support
for smoke-free playgrounds
um and we know that you know we found 97
wanted playgrounds to be smoke-free back
when we surveyed people in 2019.
now this is a key point i quite like to
mention is national legislation would
make the work of councils much easier in
this space
and so and would support your mandate
we really urge you to submit on the
government's current smoke free
action plan in 2025 and request that
they include smoke-free outdoor areas in
this plan
currently the only legislative national
nationally legislative places are
schools
sees kura and kuang rio um
and all the rest of it is piecemeal by
cancer councils
so different across the country so
obviously having better consistency by
national legislation will be much better
banning filters is another area that
they asking for feedback on
and obviously this would substantially
reduce litter issues and
you know help the work that you do
because currently it's just
councils having to deal with themselves
and volunteer organizations
uh worth noting that filters not only
are harmful to the environment where
they leech toxins but they also do not
reduce harm from smoking and actually
cause more harm
making it less unpleasant to smoke
easier for young people to start and
cause contribute to more aggressive
types of cancer
so i have emailed some of your council
staff and the mayor and deputy me some
information to support you to write a
submission and would be very happy to
send that to other interested
counsellors
and to support you in any way to do that
um
we'd also be keen for waterfall water
fountains and bottle refill stations to
be included in new developments
and would be highly recommend
not marketing alcohol or other harmful
commodities
on any council-owned and funded areas
again these measures that i'm promote
proposing are about reducing cancer
rates
and the people these measures will
protect are not just statistics they're
real people in our community and this is
our watch
thank you and if there's time for any
questions i'll try to answer them we've
still got time bridget thank you for
your submission councillor pottinger
thank you um my questions around the uh
sunlight sunshine what's your
view on its contribution to vitamin d
which is very essential to human
health uh knowing that in winter people
get sick
because of lack of vitamin d vitamin d
is definitely very important so
should we take supplements or should we
get it from the sun we have a
vitamin d policy um
position statement that can be
consistent statement that can be
referred to
um it is a sort of it's an
area that is current still evolving um
definitely like the further south we are
the less
you know lower uv we get and also it's
colder so we're more likely to cover up
a lot
so potentially some people should take
vitamin d supplements we recommend that
people talk to their gp about that
so people with darker skin find it
harder to produce the vitamin d
and people who have to keep covered for
like if you've had skin cancer and you
have to make sure you don't get
sunburned and stuff i'm just talking
about the average person
getting vitamin d honestly is that okay
well if you're out in the sun for too
long then you actually stop
producing like it sort of breaks down um
so you can be sun smart and still
get vitamin d but it is it's a tricky
balance and honestly the science is
still evolving in that area
because lots of the studies have been
done in like places in europe and stuff
that aren't
the equivalent uv level to us
we're sort of comparable to spain if you
compare us to spain in terms of the uv
that we get
so i can't really give you an answer off
the top of my head i'm not really
prepared for that but
you can check out the consensus station
statement on our website and see what
they say
but a general thing is to say seek
advice from your gp
and still don't get sunburned because
it's bad
so bridget if i'm understanding the the
gist of your submission
what what you're saying is that we
should provide some shade options and
playgrounds where they don't exist
you're not looking for them to be
completely covered i'm not looking for
you to mandate everyone stays completely
covered and never sees the sun
no but shade options definitely and
you know we do want to prevent skin
cancers and access some
thank you councillor kit yeah
thank you for your submission um
being a former smoker i haven't smoked
for about 31 years congratulations i was
a heavy smoker but i have lost some very
close friends through
smoking and it's sort of
alarming to me that the smoking rate in
invercargill is very high is there any
reason for that is to do with stress or
anything if you've done any research on
it
well the some of it will be
there'll be multiple factors involved
with this in general in
cities like big cities smoking rates
seem to be lower
um we part of it will be
having quite spread out populations and
having
like lots of rural populations and stuff
where they don't get as easily access to
smoking cessation programs and stuff
like that
it is yeah it is i'm not entirely sure
why
but i think you know we can do more to
support people definitely
um yeah yeah
no i'm not unsure only show off the top
of my head why we have
slightly higher than nationally right
one further question uh
it's amazing to see the amount of people
that are that are vaping
as those vaping devices or the
stuff they use it has been thoroughly
tested or will time tell if it is going
to cause
damage to the body or not there is heaps
of research still going on in that space
so far we can say that it's not as
harmful as smoking which is not hard
because
smoking when used resurrected kills two
out of three of its users
um but we definitely know that it will
not be harmless
so it is you know we are very concerned
at the people who are vaping especially
those who
who are not doing it to stop smoking if
you were switching over entirely
then that's probably on the long term
going to be beneficial but to be honest
it's only been around for the last
10 years or so so we really won't know
the long-term outcomes for a long time
which is why i'm really pleased that
you've incorporated
vapefree into your policy because we
don't want young people starting and we
you know want people to only use it as a
method for stopping smoking because that
is more harmful
yeah thank you very much thank you
councillors thank you bridget for your
submission
and for speaking to it this morning we
appreciate it thank you
uh jared next submission is from healthy
families just up front i am on the
leadership group for healthy families
but haven't taken part in any of the
discussions
that have led to the submission welcome
jared welcome stella
thank you modena floor is yours thank
you very much curtis coco your worship
councillors and council staff
i'm jerry cappy have families invocable
manager from sports south and this is
stella o'connor she's a
lead systems innovator um we'd like to
thank the macau city council for its
continued partnership
um on a number of our initiatives over
the last six years
um all working towards a vision of a
healthy happy safe
and connected community in particular
like thanks to the park and recreation
team um the roading team and the urban
planners um
we've done a lot of work in the cbd over
the last year around the inverse play
trail
and some work around parks thank you
darren for being on our strategic
leadership group for nearly seven years
um really appreciate your support
dedication and um
and leadership to help create a healthy
community
and we'd also like to thank the icc and
sdc for investing
um through wakato tahi funding into our
shared active transport role this is
sports south and then our health
families invocable team um we're hopeful
that this can be extended beyond an
initial nine-month
contract the role is dedicated to
increasing act to travel across
invercargill
and the southern district and has is
having a great impact to raise
visibility for councils
reading a coordinated approach for
transport across the region
yeah so issue one city centre master
plan and urban play space
health families in volcago has a
dedicated place systems innovative lead
and through our community engagements
such as pop-up play activations
at madureiki festival surveys and
interviews over five years
have indicated whanau want to see more
social bumping spaces to play in the cbd
whanau are looking for something
innovative fun interactive
which caters across the generations and
that's a key word to think about across
generations
um youth tell us there's a lack of
places to meet up and have fun in the
cbd i know i was identified in the
mumpsy report in 2010 it comes through
our community alcohol reports
and it's come through our engagements
around play and physical activity
um where you know we've presented the
last version with a video from you from
different parts of our community
saying they want a cool place to come
back to that's what they're leaving so
it's very important we have something
for the youth as well rangatahi
we're currently leading and prototyping
for the duration of the redevelopment
an intergenerational inverse play trial
in the cbd in partnership with invicaro
city council teams
enabling retailers group and invocable
central limited
so um what the place has just has been
finalized today and installed
and we've got the play container
uncontained play on this street which is
about to be turned to the east
we've got table tennis outside the
auction house and there's about to be
um some art easels outside of wakatoya
um soon and all complement
innovating streets um projects as well
um this is based off community insights
and voices over those
five years of activations and we know
through implementation
um this will further the conversation
and feedback
loops that can help go into what a a
play space could look like destination
and place places this is based on themes
whanau and youth have been asking for
such as intergenerational interactive
music and art themes and options for
youth and adults like table tennis
cornhole
connect4 and tvl um there's heaps of
other options and things they wanted as
well but based on budget and available
space we've just gone with
what we think were the main themes for
this initial play trial um research
indicates that 79 percent of shoppers
spend more time shopping because of play
facilities
and 77 percent of shoppers state that
play facilities
influence the decision on where to shop
so it's very important that we
we think about that with our cbd and
just like to say thank you for
putting it in the long term plan i'd
also like to suggest there's an anchor
point destination play space
but also other smaller play spaces that
link to and from the anchor point
location
this would integrate place rivers
through the cbd and a world
allow the community to move around the
cbd which also encourages active
transport
helps people you know spend time and
visit other shops as well
but also provide a fun safe and thriving
destination point for whanau to meet
i've asked i've raised it many times
before and meetings and workshops master
planning workshops
we definitely and friends currently meet
and our cbd as a central meeting point
and not one person can say that's where
we go
hands down but i can say in queenstown
we've got a waterfront playground and
wanaka we can go to
the dinosaur park or the new partner
just just put in down the road or
upgrade it
so this you know be really cool to have
that destination point to families come
meet us safe they know that's where
they start but they can also go out and
play and explore the cbd and the water
master
the planned area furthermore we're
asking invical city council on behalf of
hundreds of whanau and community members
who support and want play in our cbd
to invest and create free accessible
opportunities
to encourage intergenerational play
during the river
redevelopment and the future so their
cbd is attractive vibrant appealing
for whanau to come and stay and truly be
a place city with heart
thanks jared so obviously um we're
lending our support to the urban clay
space but we also want to lend our
support to the our preferred option for
the southland museum and art gallery
our insights indicate that whanau have
been missing
the all-weather option that the
treasured and loved museum offered
this is an opportunity to future proof
this asset
and we support the preferred option due
to the accessibility of parking and
access to queens park green space
we see the museum as a community hub
which incorporates learning
discovery and celebrates waihopi and
muruhiku's cultural past
and we would encourage future
development to consider the use of
intergenerational play and physical
activity
so the and the museum we feel should
connect to the cbd via safe
trans active transport options
so how in summary healthy families
invercargill looks forward to continuing
a partnership
with the council which focuses on
equitable
health outcomes and supporting the
well-being of our community
this centers on creating social and
physical environments which make it
easier for the community to make
healthier choices
including a more resilient food system
which supports food security and
sovereignty
easy access to drinking water in the
community including
water bottle filling stations active
transport which meets the needs of the
community
quality opportunities across play active
recreation and sport
smoke-free spaces and reducing the harm
from hazardous alcohol
and also supporting the community
engagement process to understand
what it takes for communities to be
healthy
happy safe and connected healthy
families invocable is a dedicated
workforce here to support communities to
lead healthy and active lives through
local solutions for local people
and we value our partnership with the
invercargill city council
and look forward to continuing working
alongside to help create a city with
heart
thank you very much thanks dylan thank
you jared councillors
councillor pottinger thank you straight
to the museum
one okay this this uh
you you've said it's a great hub you
know being in queens park
and you you like um places that
then engage with the environment around
it you know
open spaces so under the current uh
refurbishment of the museum it's not
going to really change much in its
layout
inside if you went new
you have the potential of north facing
orient you know having it work into the
park
you could have something more exciting
so would you support
something that was new and exciting and
could work better with the park
as flowing into the park rather when
you're inside the museum at the moment
it's very
very closed or would you just be happy
with doing it up
well i think the main thing is that our
community have told us how much
they miss they miss the museum oh yeah
no that's not the point
i'm saying i'm asking you it's an
opportunity obviously to look
forward and obviously looking using the
green space there and looking into it
would be perfect
i think i'm nodded after stadium as well
it's about
future focus being innovative and
creative and thinking about
20 30 years down the track so how do we
make it the best it can be and thinking
about the long term not about
just now so we really need to think
about that and it's around families
whanau
you know discovery learning i was the
representation review
2013 i think i went to one of the
meetings here i was listening to the
community talk around
why they go to queens park and you know
well before the museum was
you know talked about this but it's just
so important to them and
memories were going there to see the
tuatara and to engage and spend time and
then go to queen's park and
walk around the park and they're making
a dive and it's free and low cost so
it's really important to
think about that that shouted free and
low cost and
families need to learn it needs to cater
for a large number of people
i appreciate that jared said well
councillor soper then councillor scout
thank you
um i just wanted to clarify you've
referred to
urban play spaces so are you saying
overall
rather than a margaret mayhe like
one destination urban play space
your preference would be for multi
yeah smaller play spaces i think there
should be one anchor point destination
play space which family will come and
meet and that's the the hub
but also thinking that you know okay
there's quite a few
there's one on simsharp the other day
and you know one 1.5 million that was on
up north that they showed her lady
advocated for and funded which is quite
big something
big but in also small pockets of play
that caterpillar youth cater for
intergenerational play and play around
with the retail precincts of you know
it's not everyone's not going to one
point there's other options to move
around the town
at links to add to transport and and
it's great to see in our master planning
principles that
you know even places may be playing
stays in there so the whole city is
looking at
at play as well so just speaking about
that
and in the plan so it's a hub and spoke
model that you're
yeah yeah and that's sort of part of
what we've got the play trail
prototyping
you know you're in the next month all
the the sites are
up and running and then we can really
evaluate that and see how people move
and
how they play in the feedback we know
the feedback from the option housing
table tennis
as fantastic as young to
final question councillor scout i thank
you through cheer and
just to follow on from council sopra
thank you for the professional
presentation stella and jared i'm just
i'm really
the youth are really dear to us all and
obviously it's a major issue for us
in retaining our youth so just want to
dig deep
dig a little deeper regarding um the
youth and the comments we
made around the youth the meeting place
the play place
and the various activities pop-up
activities are you saying to us that it
needs to be a combination of those
what the youth are looking for and i
guess you've connected with this youth
council as well
but so it's a multi-purpose
multi-functional
opportunity is that where we is yeah so
youth are meeting
in car parks at the moment
and obviously it's not a great place for
them to meet
okay 100 nodules we have to disc golf in
queens park to
you know you support them thank you
again for that but it's that's young and
older going there you know
it's that's one of the business assets
in queens park and
that's what the youth wanted they wanted
in queens park and they said they'd use
it
but we were hoping it'll be
intergenerational and it is
and they're using it and they're not
asking for the same and the cbd places
to hang out have fun
interactive and that's why they're
typical cornhole
table tennis but also we need to play
across the ages children but adults can
play as well we just forget the place on
time and our creativity
the ministers over time so yeah thank
you
thank you jared thank you stella thank
you for your submission and making the
time available to come along and speak
to it this morning
we appreciate it brendan
welcome along brendan thank you
thank you for your submission on behalf
of sports south and obviously you're
familiar with the process so the floor
is yours
thank you call brittany mcdermott
chief executive support southampton i
guess like jared and stella firstly i'd
like to thank you
the council and congratulate you and
your team for the work that you're doing
in the cargo and bluff
i'm sure the tough decisions that are
made in the work being done is often
taken for granted
and so i want to thank you for your
investment and the time and your
investment you make
to allow our community to be active
through play active recreation and sport
in addition i'd like to congratulate you
on now having a dedicated leisure and
recreation
role which highlights the importance of
this area
and thank claire and your various teams
for your solution focused
and collaborative approach with sports
southland our relationship has gone from
strength to strength in the last few
years
and i believe as a result we're seeing a
lot better outcomes
as two different organizations i believe
we have the same kaupapa
we both want happy healthy connected
people
and communities where everyone can
thrive sport southland is not just about
sport
we're here to enhance individual and
community wellbeing through being active
in whatever way that looks like so
whilst a large
uh a lot of the large dollar investment
decisions
that you have in front of you involve
assets and infrastructure
it's important not to forget about
investing and well-being
to ensure that these happy healthy and
connected people in our communities
will continue to use these assets for
years to come
yes it's important we have these assets
and the environment
but let's make sure we maximize the use
of our spaces and make sure the
community actually use them
and more of our community can use them
if we want a city with heart
we need to make sure we have a heartbeat
and that heartbeat comes from the people
and our community with regard to our
written submission
and some of the issues raised we support
the following options issue one
we support the preferred preferred
option to invest in urban place basal
spaces
we know play is a vital part of a young
person's physical and cognitive
development but players also
inter-generational as jared and stella
said
and provides both physical and social
outcomes for our community
and we shouldn't forget the social
outcomes and the benefits that arise
from those
issue three we support the preferred
option to invest
into our regional outdoor rectangular
stadium
especially given the emphasis on making
the facility more flexible and more
multi-use
it's not just a rugby stadium this
project aligns
well with the proposed regional spaces
and places strategy
and being part of the governance group i
want to congratulate you as a council
and the way that you went about this
involving councillors rugby
representatives independent
uh community representatives and
ourselves in that process
and i believe this is a model that we
should continue to use in the future
we will also support the sorry park
grandstand renewal
but we suggest that the council delay
the project until it is time to work
with its current users
until they have time to investigate a
more flexible multi-use
facility which may be to meet their
needs as you heard from chris knight
and gordon crumble yesterday there was a
willingness for these users to see what
is possible
and look at a facility that maximizes
its use and being used by multiple users
which leads me on to and i've referred
to rio i guess this the regional space
and places strategy
over the past 18 months we've been
working alongside your team
other councils and funders with the
development of the southam regional
space and places strategy
which is now ready for adoption and
endorsement by all the organizations
involved
one of the key successes of the project
to date has been the positive
conversations
and sharing that has happened
collectively and collaboratively between
the council's funders and ourselves
we now have a strategy a good stock
taker facilities
and good momentum of working together
let's not lose the momentum
it's con it's key that we continue this
mahi
and we propose that all parties invest
collaboratively and a small resource to
keep the strategy and the actions moving
forward
this resource will work alongside
councils funders and applicants
of new facilities ensure that we have
better information to support decision
making
and help better utilize and maximize the
potential of the assets that we have now
and look to build in the future so the
sports house and board have already
adopted the strategy and we're looking
to
allocate and invest 40 of the resource
cost
and are looking to councils and funders
to partner with us over the next three
years to ensure the regional space in
places strategy
is implemented well and doesn't just
become another strategy on the shelf
as a key partner a partner who would be
a major beneficiary of the work
we're looking to you to invest 20
percent of the of the
rolls which is 40 thousand dollars per
annum
in the cargo city council we have a
number of sport and recreation
facilities on its land
a large number of these facilities are
single use
and or seasonal facilities that vary in
quality
with most only rating average to good
condition
if we can better utilize and maximize
the potential of these assets by working
with groups earlier
we can help prevent these facilities
becoming a liability for council
and we've already got examples of some
of those liabilities of sports walking
away from their club rooms and
facilities
it's critical that we make it taken more
strategic
aligned and collective approach to
future investment into our sport and
recreation facilities
by being a partner you have also the
opportunity to access sport new zealand
funding as you did for the rugby park
and sorry park
fun projects as a key partner your
support and leadership is critical
without it i think we're unlikely to get
our other partners to commit
therefore missing the opportunity to
fully realize the opportunity that this
strategy presents
so in closing i want to reiterate my
thanks
uh thank you for your time your
investment and your commitment
uh both as a council and your teams for
the people of indonesia and bluff
sport south and looks forward to
continue and grow our partnership with
you
and together grow our partnership with
our community where we work together for
our city
a city with a strong beating heart thank
you
thanks brandon um if i can pick up on on
surrey park because sports south and
were a part of the
the group that formulated the report and
as you identified we had submissions
yesterday from waihopa afc
and um south and athletics calling for a
pause
while everybody um looks at how they can
collaborate
do you have any any any sense any feel
for how long that that needs to be
i think there needs to be work done to
ensure that
not just the existing users but are
there any other potential users so um
i think 12 months and again i think
that's with a role
and investing in some resource we can
make that happen quicker if we've got
some resource to make that happen
so the the resource that we're talking
about can actually then help
to facilitate those conversations uh
which makes a quicker outcome for
council and those users and that's
recognizing i guess that you're dealing
with
groups that are populated by volunteers
yep thank you
councillors uh councillor cricket i just
wanted noted that um
i haven't had anything to do with this
submission
because you're on the board of sports so
as a trustee um
obviously have an interest but it is not
pecuniary and i haven't had anything to
do with the submission itself
thanks alex noted any other questions
for brendan
nigel now thank you to you cheer brendan
thank you for the
once again the professional um
submission um
fantastic see the collaborative approach
coming from the sports background
obviously great to see
um working with steve and the team and
and the community funders to get where
we've got to with this
plan going forward i'm really interested
in
rugby park is a little bit contentious
in the sense of
um you mentioned the opportunity of
multi-purpose multi-functional
uh going forward as a way forward are
there any current barriers perhaps in
the sense of the usage that you've found
over time through
either your organization or feedback
from other sports organizations
around the opportunity of utilizing that
green field
because obviously it's um it's a rugby
designated venue
but we've had some examples in the past
of having um
some community sports days we've had
nigeria circus we've had some events
but obviously it's a big financial drag
as well have you and your team had any
other thoughts of how we might be able
to
make it more multi-purpose more
multifunctional um
and better used by the wider community
i think some of that is going to come
down to a mindset shift that it is more
than just a rugby stadium
uh i think steve and the team are
already looking to invest
in in someone who can actually drive the
activation of
of a facility like that i think if the
environment is different
it looks and feels like a rugby stadium
if through the proposed
uh recommendations we're opening up the
facility so there's other spaces within
there that then encourage other users to
be part of that
we're making it accessible on regular
occasions
for other users to use it then i think
we'll start to get the community use
happening
uh again using the likes of ourselves
and other community partners to then
drive their activation as well so it
doesn't have to be something that
council do on its own
but it can be do done as a collaborative
approach
and just further um through each year
just
has has the price of of renting the
space or hiring the space been a barrier
in the past or has it been
i know from being involved in the um
in the triathlon club that that's not a
barrier i mean i think we pay
150 or whatever it is for it to use that
for a kids triathlon so i don't think
that's the barrier
i think it's a mindset shift that this
is not just a rugby stadium
and that we've actually got dedicated
resource that's driving
outcomes to get people using it if we
don't invest the time and
i guess i come back to my submission
where we talk about it's investing the
time on that activation piece not just
build the asset and they will come
because we all know we have to actually
put the work in to get them there
thank you thank you and nicely timed
brendan thank you very much for the
submission from false sports southland
and for coming along this morning to
speak to we appreciate it thank you and
thank you also for the recognition of
the partnership roles that we've had
thanks southern farmers market dave
welcome along dave obviously you also
are not unfamiliar with our processes so
thanks very much the floor is yours very
appreciate this opportunity to
talk to you all today and i'd like to
also acknowledge the support from this
council
after the carved lockdown we lacked a
space to operate from
and you worked really well with us to
provide us the scottish hall
space and we managed to operate there at
a low cost
which was really appreciated and that
helped us bridge a gap
that was really helpful to us i'd also
like to acknowledge that at the moment
we're operating from the race course and
peter kett is involved with that
committee and we've really appreciated
their support
but there's a long-term view that we'd
like to put before this council
so the southern farmers market for those
that aren't aware of us
we're a non-profit organisation uh
incorporated society so we exist to kind
of manage the space
so that local producers
and growers can have a place to operate
from so we don't have a lot of money we
try and keep costs
as low as possible so they're there
still holders can operate it
you know the overheads for them are very
limited we also consider
ourselves to be an enterprise incubator
so any small business
can have a go at their market to test a
product and see if their business is
viable so we
feel we provide a valuable economic
asset
i've also estimated that we probably
have a turnover of economic activity
through a market
over a million dollars a year so we
provide
substantial economic value to the city
as well
we have around 30 to 40 stalls attending
our market throughout the year at the
moment
and we provide employment for around 100
individuals
so quite substantial so
air support is for the city
issue number one the city center master
plan and urban play space
and what we would like you to consider
in the the long term
is a space that's a multi-purpose space
that perhaps the market could operate
from
one of their main issues is in bad
weather is having shelter
often it's wind i've given a
i think if you've looked at the
submission i provided there's an
illustration there of an idea i thought
that had merit
off um and sort of in all a covered
space that allows light to come in
could have you know grass underneath and
so it could be used in summer and
winter but if need be it could have some
drop down sides and things
and it could be used for concerts and
all sorts of other things other than the
farmers market
but i think that's probably something
that we've identified
is lacking in the city centre is a
multi-purpose kind of public space
um and we would really be grateful for
something uh like that in the future we
are
also keen to support anything
that um activates um activity
in the in the center we're looking at
taking part in the street activation
um on the 23rd um we've still got a few
logistical things
um that we have to have satisfied before
we'll take part and it's a bit
short notice so i think one of the
things that
are holding back some of the still
holders is the level of promotion but
kathy jordan assures me that that's
going to be really good
but there's a night event coming up and
we think that you know
our market could provide value for
events like that
so i just want to put it out there that
um
we're a institution that adds value to
the economic activity of the city
and it would be really great in the
future perhaps to have a purpose-built
space
that we could operate from at low cost
so that
those beginning enterprises can start
off loan overheads
and they could be the potential success
stories of
of south and in terms of economic
development
thanks dave councillors over here for
questions councillor lush
yeah look um i appreciate that the
experience
i mean well done with the farmers market
i appreciate the experience that the
racecourse is not right it's not as good
as once it was um for all sorts of
reasons is anderson's parking are used
to or is it too far out of town
um well i mean the race course operates
really well it's got good
parking close by and we sort of
appreciate that but the experience is
that
what we find is that there's little
street visibility
and when we have operated from the
centre we can actually take part in
things that are happening in the town
centre
so we're a destination at the racecourse
which means that people have to know
that we're there
and come to there so our customers kind
of start dropping off about half an hour
before we
we close but we found that when we're
operating the center of the city
passing traffic means that we keep busy
constantly and we're constantly coming
across new
customers so if the burt monroe rally
for example was happening in the center
of the city and we're operating from
there
we just add value to anything that's
happening so if you have a choice
between the race course and
moving to a place in town is that is it
how you look at it we
we would look at it as long as it meet
all their needs at the moment the
racecourse is taking lots of boxes in
terms of having some shelter and bad
weather
and that's really important to us so
often
you know we've been offered spaces that
don't have good covered areas
and we need electricity as well for some
of their stores too
thank you councillor clark then
councillor arnold
yeah thank you chair um dave um just
about the issue around town have you got
any
places that you could see could be used
and why i ask that is it
i noticed in wellington they have a very
vibrant uh farmers market there
and they they've got an arrangement with
the city council up there where they
block off
part of the car parking area by
te papa right every weekend and so
there's there's somewhere in town that
you could see that like frames like the
car park across the road next to the
um well as i said i think the issue is
that um
you know there are a lot of car parks
around that were closed off we could
utilize those
in good weather one of the good things
about the racecourse at the moment is in
a really nice day
that grassed area um that we have there
has got a really lovely atmosphere
so if we did shift one place i did look
at and i know it's now
controlled by the number 10 trust but
the old bowling green
at the corner of devron and east street
if that had a cover over the top
and then the potential to drop down
sides from the weather side
and bad weather you could have a space
there where you could have buskers
operating and people having lunch
you know during the day and then it
would be an ideal kind of square
situation for other events
so if you have a look at that picture
that i that i provided if you imagine
that on top of the number 10 because of
the grass space it could actually be
your goal
councillor arnold next year andrew um
dave
you partially answered my question and i
was going to say you know
a frequently quite regularly over the
last eight months or so
and there's not a nicer place to sit on
a sunny afternoon
that's really really nice do you not
feel that you'd lose that
that sort of relaxing sort of vibrant
atmosphere if it just become
a stall thing like it's almost it's a
dis it is a destination at the
racecourse but it's right
it almost feels like it is a place to go
to
hang out if you like buy a bit of stuff
on a sunday morning
you don't think you might lose that if
you move to town because
there'll be nowhere to sit the same as
that you lose a feeling i think wouldn't
you
um when we operated from the masonic uh
we had an open area where people could
sit
and um the reserve um
ashipuni gardens were just across the
way so there was access to places where
people could have picnics and things
that kind of worked i mean the thing is
that that
you have to look at the air overall and
for us we really struggle to
to for our stall holders to to make
money
on wet windy days when we're um and
it's a an effort for people to get into
you know they have to make an effort to
go to a place
if we're operating from a place where
people are already coming to anyway
we already have a certain customer base
that will pass through but if they just
have to make an effort on a bad day
to go to a different place you know some
people have said we've surveyed our
customers
and they said they quite like to be able
to go um
to a place where there's a lot of things
happening and they can
do a number of activities at the same
time so for instance when we're
operating at the masonic lodge i think a
lot of people would come to our market
what they couldn't buy in their market
they might nip into pack and save
afterwards
so and when we operated from um
the scottish hall in the past um i think
h j smith supported us with electricity
because they saw there was a symbiotic
relationship between
us operating from there and then they
got um
custom as well so what we see are kind
of building partnerships too that was
your last sunday as well yeah yeah
yeah okay thank you councillors thank
you dave for that submission on behalf
of the
farmer's market the next item
is for invercargill public art gallery
and
i see linly's here so dave's name next
to it but your name's at the bottom of
the report
welcome along thank you thank you very
much for the submission and taking the
time to
to come along this morning uh we've got
10 minutes to get a bell halfway through
that's not somebody arriving for fish
and chips
you can either use the full 10 uh but it
does limit our opportunity to ask
questions
look i'll be very brief really um i
wanted to just
um front actually to support and uh
so you can see the face and support our
submission opportunity for if you've got
any um
questions of us i use the first thing
the issue that we did submit on in a
fairly brief way was
around the city centre master plan and
really we're signaling that we see
ourselves
as key stakeholders there
we're uh up for um being part
of uh increasing the vibrancy and being
part of this
um you know the city centre master plan
and
however that may look and we're already
actively working with the various groups
that are working on it so it was really
just signaling our
support and um recognizing that although
with the invercargill public art gallery
that we are keen to um
you know art doesn't just sit inside the
gallery and that if we can be part of
the inner
uh city uh work we would like to do that
and the second was our probably our main
point we wish to and i just wish to
emphasize that we do
support as a board um the preferred
option of for the invical city to
and continue down the pathway of
investing
in a new museum
new zealand art gallery and that while
there were two
options put there our submission
is that the city proceeds
down the path of a new museum and art
gallery
or renovated one however that may look
although
we also did make the point that we think
that we are at this point investing a
lot of money investing for the future
of our city and that um that we should
be getting as high earthquake
building and building standards and as
high earthquake safety
rating as as possible so um the only
uh the little rider we there was a
another option around
that um submission and that was that a
significant amount of money be put into
um hey wakatuia which is our current
exhibition space
um i think what we're saying is that
there's probably going to be
a midway and we do understand that this
we're submitting to the long term plan
what we're signaling though is that um
once the council makes the decision
as to what's going to happen with the
museum and art gallery space that
there may need to be some interim um
additional support to hey wakatoya if we
continue to develop
and become vibrant develop our staff
have the right people
maintain the interest in the arts in the
city so that we're ready
for our new facility and how that may
look so
we understand we're not submitting on
that we're signaling that
um there could you know need to be a
part
way or an interim solution through the
annual plan process once
the um you know once the
uh the long-term plan is finalized
um i just would like to though take an
opportunity here
very briefly to acknowledge the
collaboration that's gone on
um over the last couple of years i'd
like to acknowledge the work
um of the of the city council and their
staff
getting us through our development
during a very rocky
phase of covert and um managing to get
um
alongside our
museum and art gallery colleagues
to actually get an opening exhibition
space that is working well
we it it's probably
we've had that little part of the last
year
where we were just tentative every
flipping opening that we tried to have
was
um shut down um and so we haven't had
the opportunity to have the big
um you know the big rara so we're very
conscious of our visibility we think
we've still got more work to do on that
we've got a a very full plan
for the next year where the exhibition
plan is
is absolutely full of exciting and new
things
but probably just signaling our
resources
at doing what we've got planned for this
year are at max so
if we're looking to extend that and to
do some more innovative things we would
be looking to get some extra support for
staffing and development and
some resourcing so thanks lindley that's
me
councillors over here for questions
councillor sofa
thank you mr chair i just thought i
should probably declare
councillor lewis and i should probably
declare that we are appointees
by council on to invercargill public art
gallery incorporated
um and councillor keit is the mayor's
appointee
and we didn't have anything to do with
putting together the submission
that we enjoy i think and you're not
allowed to ask questions
we enjoy the energy of the ipad
thank you thank you we've certainly had
a lot of uh hard to believe but we've
certainly had a lot of fun and has been
a lot of enthusiasm
and it's been um great to be some part
of something really positive
um at a time when i think we all of us
struggled didn't we and we are conscious
of visitor numbers and
really working hard on improving
positive numbers so we've already
increased
our days opening days and length of days
and tried some flexible things around
days
um i think i was reading something this
morning actually just talking about um
engaging all new zealanders back in the
arts and culture
and i think we need to look at our
demographic and
work really hard because i'm i mean i
work in the aged care sector
and i think there's still quite a number
of our
citizens and our people that are still a
little bit anxious about
getting out and about and coming into
things they might have previously
enjoyed
so we're very conscious of that thank
you
thanks emily and thanks for your
submission and coming along to speak to
it this morning thank you no other
questions
oh sorry councillor clark thank you
chair uh lilly just one issue on the um
the issue that you raised about the new
building standard you prefer the
strengthening to go up to 100 um it's
my understanding that to get an existing
building up 100 percent is
nigh on impossible and the cost is
astronomic so
given that and given the questions that
council pondered us previous submitters
on the
on the museum okay is that a factor for
you that
would tip you towards more towards a new
museum as opposed to a
refurbishment of the existence well i
mean look i'm not an engineer but i'm
not
silly either so um i you know i think
that
um uh yeah that in my view i mean i
haven't heard those other questions i
wouldn't have that but
um it it did seem to me that we should
be really future proofing as we go
forward
and see if we can and i understand the
council already made
you know part way down that process but
i guess we're just saying as we get into
the planning and the real detail
um that if there's a chance to review
that you may decide to
and we should have our support to do
that thank you
thanks lonely okay yep thank you sell
one
thanks for waiting patiently
thank you very much i'm going to sort of
take a slightly different tack for a
start and i want to
talk about the council membership and
the system of uh
election um i want to excuse myself
to you going forward could you bring the
microphone a little closer please
thanks going forward that um
we you look going back to the ward
system we used to have uh
bush ward community board the blackboard
and and then
the rest of the city over time the
bush and the ototarium board were
discontinued but bluff is still there
and i'm just saying that you could cut
council down to eight
at plus mir if you went to award system
award system i'm a great believer in it
it
gives a great diversity around the table
and
really a better representation of
from the ratepayers and when i say you
can go to eight
north east west south bluff um
centre city and a couple of internal
city
uh you could quite easily represent
the community very well with that
smaller number
around this table
the uh road map i looked at that i
thought
man alive what a dream list this is you
know it's
it's massive they're all good causes
but let's face it
you've spent a lot of money in the
center city at this stage
and it's time probably to take two steps
back
let the center city development
finish and be up and running before you
start going into
other big spending items because every
big item you
build in the city is going to require
maintenance
not now but in 50 60 years time
so it's not just building it's
maintaining what has already been built
and we see that with the stadium
now the rating increase uh seven percent
i believe you know the community is
struggling out there
and you've got to listen to them and uh
you know you've got to try and bring
that down at least under five percent i
know it was quite low
through the covert so um otherwise i
would have been saying three percent but
you know you've just got to
take into consideration of the general
population that's trying to survive
uh in a very harsh uh situation at this
point of time
i just lost myself in here
where'd it go
sorry
now the um
roadmap if you put them all into 10
years it's just ridiculous so you've got
to bring it right down
and i i'm going slightly different to um
probably what a lot of other people were
saying but there's things like the water
tower
it's a it's an icon for the city it has
been talked about by
don't know how long around this table
but what you're going to do with it
uh it's not a lot of money an overall
picture so get the thing done get it
sorted
it's another that's provided the
observation deck
is operational it's something local
great players can enjoy and also
visitors
can enjoy so i think that's it's a
smaller item in
in your bigger thing anderson park is
the other one
how long we talked about anderson it's
been talked about anderson park
to get it uh going it's sat there it's
got into beds to state get it up just
get it running get at least out and and
that's another item off the list not a
big item
but it's it's something that is
an asset that has to be maintained and
it's been neglected
i i was also the next one i thought the
third one on the list was the surrey
park stand because i'm really impressed
with the athletic society and how they
maintain that track and and see the
number of
people especially young children and
athletics and
seniors as well but it's nice to see
that they're saying hey we want to
do something take a step back but
i think it's a far more important one
than the rugby park because i mean i
look at rugby park and say
it's just not been used you know it's a
big block
the council got duped into taking over
the land originally
and now we have fines of the
stand not been so good so i believe that
needs to be parked
until um that
more use can be found for that now the
urban play centre
um i'm saying hey look queens park is
our place centre in the city
if you're spending money that's where it
should go and queen's park could do with
a bit more
uh there as well can i carry on just
slightly
yes it shortens the amount of time for
questions but that's your choice
the um
urban play that i think it should be
i'm just a bit lost with
why you want to do urban play in the
center of the city when we've got
beautiful parks
and queens park could be extended quite
considerably
the master streetscape i'm really having
sir 20 million dollars uh what are you
trying to do
you got to tidy up around the new city
center block
that's fine do that put it five million
dollars into there
but spending uh a whole lot of money
in the center city at this time on
roading and foot bars and all the rest
of it
it's going to take five years for
traffic flows
footpath uh use to settle down
once the new step block is up and
operating so give it time to settle
before you start
doing other alterations to within the
the city
now the big one with the museum i
believe it's um
it's a hot potato i suppose these days
is yeah get it up and running as least
money possible just to
get it
earthquake proofed but at the same time
put some money aside
for the long term plan of
with taking the community with you are
you going to eventually
demolish it and build a purpose built
interactive type museum which i think
you should do
but not now not probably in this 10
years
maybe at the end of the next 20 years
you'll have
something that to be really city to be
worthwhile
but put the money aside for
concept design and public
input so that everyone you take everyone
on board with you
when it happens
i think really all the rest of the
things that on the long term plan
leave them over there to the next next
plan because you've got one heck of a
lot of things happening in the city
and things are changing and i notice
that
online shopping has gone up 37 so things
are going to change
dramatically in this 10 years cycle
so be prudent
take two steps back and i know there's
people saying i want to get this built
and i want to get that built
it's not what i want to do it's what the
general public need
to survive and we're all surviving quite
nicely thank you at the moment
so you know it is nice to haves not need
to haves
so i thank you for your time thanks so
much i hope your initial comments about
the award system you've also passed on
to the representation review which is
running at the moment
no i have not uh but when i
left council i said i didn't want to
come back here
but uh once i saw the the road plan
i thought i've gotta step up and say
something anyway
thanks the the chair of the review
committee is here and you your your
feedback is noted
yeah and in your submission so when you
you talk about
um uh our rate of borrowing
um which i can assure you is not ego
driven
um just to show that i did read it um do
you not
feel that for projects where the
benefits are inter-generational that
these are long-term projects that the
cost of it should be spread
over a greater period rather than in in
one hit
in order to not borrow money i i
totally agree but once you start getting
your uh rate uh
and deafness which you're looking at
going up to 200 percent i'm saying
i can't run a business with a debt value
like that
i can't run my own private life with a
debt uh anything like that
and a council should be no different
that's what i'm saying
just keep that debt level spread it
but do do a project do it well i'm not
against that i'm not
against spending multi-million dollars
on a good project
but do it do it once but only one at a
time
not a whole lot of things at a time some
of the small things like the
the uh tear that is
small will change really okay thank you
counselors questions
counselor scalp thank you um thanks
are you saying regarding the ward system
that eight are
more effective than 12 i believe
if it's a ward system yes
at the moment it's 12 voted at large
but it bored you're getting someone
that's normally
would be known in that community like a
bluff person
that people will know who they're voting
for and who they are and what they stand
for
and the same is spread around it i think
it's
it's more representation counselor
sorry there's three parts of that sorry
well
we are running over time now we'll flag
good i was going to say councillor
cricket is yours a brief question
because
we've got another meeting coming up
shortly yeah yeah it could be quite
brief depending on the answer
um my question was um
you you you've stated that the roadmap
to renewal the amount of projects that
we have in there is quite ambitious
you're not wrong normally this council
has undertaken
projects of considerably less um yeah
question yeah the question
sorry is what out of that list would you
prioritize
you could give me just two projects that
you think are most important rather than
a long answer yeah i just the the water
tower
quite the anderson's park
and what did i say the other one um
another one yeah yeah yeah what a tower
in anderson's house yeah those are the
two
you know they're they're pretty small
and another thing but if you're going to
pick one
pick one i'd rather you get rid of
someone like the
play thing around those bigger ones and
do one
sure yeah thank you thanks helen thank
you appreciate your submission for
coming along this morning
valerie welcome back
counselors have had a chance to uh to
read through your written submission but
obviously you've got the opportunity to
uh speak to it this morning and
highlight any uh
points of it that you'd like to draw our
attention to
and um i'd like to thank you for the
time to come in
to do this um i'm
here representing ccs disability service
and invercargill
and the things that i put into my
submission weren't mine
they were theirs um so i
i was the one who got the pic to
actually write it up and send it in for
you
um i really do appreciate this time
because
just listening to some of the um
submissions that you've
we've just talked about in the last half
an hour ours are very much in line
with that um but i guess that
um biggest priority is um
about accessibility and inclusiveness
um somebody made a comment to me once
when i was working
when i was working in disability up at
waitaki that
um a young person
is still a young person whether they
have a disability or not
in other words they have all the needs
of other
young people so personally i would like
to sort of see
a bit more maybe consultation
in the community with our young people
i chose to come here to live two years
ago
after having spent 20 years in alice
springs
and what attracted us to invercargill
was the
first of all it was sot for my daughter
and the schools my granddaughter
and also the other things and we've
discovered so much
in invercargill over the last two years
in terms of play area
play areas and things like that um
we think it's absolutely a fantastic
place to live
so i'd like to thank you all for that
um
sorry i'm quite nervous that's quite all
right valerie you're quite safe behind
that table we won't bite so
you'll see us coming
but also listening to some of those
other submissions um
it really brought home to me that there
are a lot of commonalities
in them the play areas i'll just go
through
some of the comments i made in my
submission
that sort of backs that up a little bit
so the city centre we
talked about gathering places for people
and i was in the document that said
streets are for people yes streets are
for people
but there are lots of things around that
as well in terms of people with
disabilities
it's about that access we talked about
that with public transport
um it's also about um
having a destination but how do you get
there and how do you get home again
if you've got a disability those sorts
of things so it's all very well um
previous speaker talked about
or i think one of councillors talked
about having um
uh sort of like a play area or urban
play area in the
middle of the city but i like the way
that it's all set out now
we've got three play areas within a
block of our home
um you can't beat that and we're just so
grateful for those sorts of
opportunities here and believe that
um you know if we can get it right
for one person or one young person
with a disability you can get it right
for everybody else
or most other people well probably a bit
too grand
statement there but um but yes if you
look at
um so what does a person with a
disability do
in this space what do they do how do how
do they get around it
is it lawn people with disabilities
don't just all sit in wheelchairs either
and i think we when we see the
disability
sign um that shows somebody
shows a wheelchair we tend to forget
that sometimes that it's not just
people in wheelchairs that's a lot of
other people
one of my colleagues on the local area
committee talks about
having a
different ability not a disability a
different
ability and that's so true too so
um but yes so the the play areas
um we talked also about the
market area and you've already had that
comment from a couple of people this
morning i won't go over that again
because
we just agree with that um
we agree with things like um the
museum and queen's gardens all sort of
being in one sort
of huge area um because
again it's but for us it's about
accessibility and all being able to come
in together
have family time together um have that
sort of space where you can have
the markets for example you've got that
ready access from one to the other um
and we thought the same about the sports
ground
as well yeah okay about the sports
grounds as well
that's only the halfway point valerie
don't you that's right
um about having multi um
events held around the city so that they
were all sort of utilized together and
came together to work together
um what else
uh yes um my last other plans and
activities
i've talked about council to have the
ability to undertake
research and development opportunities
in association with
sit and having been involved with both
district council and politics in the
past
that whole research and development area
where everybody's working together and
as i said i've only been here two years
you may be already doing it
but i think it's a really fantastic
opportunity
for to become quite innovative and
creative
because that is where we need to go for
the future
1931 invercargill is not going to have
the same needs as
2021 of 1931 i would show my age now
um 20 20 31
is going to have completely different
needs to 2021
in terms of technology in terms of how
we move around our cities
the needs that we have all of that sort
of stuff so
um again i endorse what somebody else
just said
previously about how we need to be
working with that
rather than um looking at what we want
now
um okay i think that's
um yeah and the other thing was about
just simply about consultation
ccs as a group really appreciate uh
relationships that we have with council
staff and
some council members in alice springs i
was part of an access
committee that had staff and
a couple of councillors and those of us
in the community that were working with
people with disabilities all come
together once every two months and just
it was just a catch up on what's
happening
why is it happening what do we need to
be planning for all of this sort of
stuff
and one of the things um about that was
things like having places to sit during
parades
there was no public seating in the
community
and i find myself struggling to walk
where do i sit down and sometimes i'm
just desperate for a sit down somewhere
so yeah i think those sorts of just they
just seem to be little things
that you can tweak to make it a little
whole lot more comfortable
for people with disabilities so you've
got my submission
um thanks valerie yes and actually um
you know quite a few of the points
you've raised particularly that last one
around
uh settings being taken up in the uh the
cityscape review that we've done we've
got time for one question
councillor sopa thanks welcome val thank
you
val um in the submission it's got
whatnot place to be revisited
i just want to absolutely clarify that's
not ccs members saying
they want us to keep waking the place
exactly as it is
is that more saying anything that we do
in the future
please look at the accessibility and
other issues around
what's currently at what the place and
do better yeah i think that's
certainly the sense of what i got from
that um person who was talking about
that
um i don't you know with not having had
that history
around town but certainly that's what i
got a feeling for because it could be
the person said it could be seen as a
great hub for gatherings for
you know sitting outside for meals for
just whatever um that and
and i guess um yeah it was
endorsed by a couple of other people as
well saying that yes they'd tried with
whatnot pace but
what's happened and where can we go so
they're looking very much for
development around that
space thank you as well i think the
other quick point i want to make is
i put in here it was about the
playgrounds consider playgrounds for
everybody
adult playgrounds disability playgrounds
absolutely
playgrounds are for everybody not for
kids but for all of us
i mean us um
yeah i'm 72 now so i'd still love a
swing
on a playground so you know you don't
have to
shut things down because of the way they
were or the way that we're used to doing
things let's be a little bit more
creative
and innovative around what we're doing
in the community
thank you thanks valerie appreciate you
coming along this morning thank you
uh councillors we are running tight for
time but we've got we'll we will
deal with uh winsom's submission before
we take a break we've got a
workshop um that we probably need to get
to over in the drawing room
and we will have time to get back here
for a lunch break following that
thank you everybody
thank you very much
for watching
and this area my um
my mother's side come from this area
um all the way back uh they were
traveling to the tt islands and when i
got here
i've been living here before years and
when i got here
i um was asked by the locals you know
are you a local because
if you're not born and bred in bluff um
and you'll know this marcus
you know it takes a lot to convince them
that you really
are into the area but you know i was
taught
waiata when i was young that included
all the names of the islands like
toki hepatia potama pohu waitai me puma
takiarehua so i've got a deep
deep connection to this land and i know
all of you have taken the jobs that
you've
you've taken because you believe that
this land is worth defending
i actually think it's a bit late i think
based on
if you've read my submission which is a
social credit submission
basically saying that while many of i've
read right through your document which
is very interesting
and there's some great um ideas for
innovation and management and building
of the infrastructure
however i'm very concerned about your
ability to pay for it
there are always constraints upon any
budget and this is really a budget
statement
and what bothers me is that
the un un
opposed from the councils throughout the
country
they do not oppose sorry the the debt
funding
of of everything so it says you're going
to borrow
uh over the next uh 10 years
another 110 approximately 110
don't quote me i could be wrong you'll
know better than i do
million dollars however where are you
borrowing it from
i happen to know where you're borrowing
it from you're borrowing it from
overseas
largely and from very wealthy kiwis this
is
wrong it means that we're losing control
because our rates are not actually
paying for everything
our rates are paying for the interest on
the money that's being borrowed
and i'm very alarmed that as tim
mentioned
that maori tanga and
kaipapa maori is now being included and
i can see it
which means to wake up a new way renewal
or looking at the way things should be
and i agree with that but maori never
ever behaved like this
they never ever borrowed to live
they didn't load debt on our mokopuna
and it's you know we're all inclusive
we're all part of this now
and it's our mokopuna and our mokopuna
and our mokapona that are going to be
paying for these um
these ventures these infrastructural
bills and what
what bothers me is this is very much not
a maori concept the maori concept is a
gift giving
not where you're loading your debt into
the future
really bothers me and it's been going on
for years and our central government
does exactly the same where do we borrow
what
largely we borrow from the four banks
the four australian banks and westpac is
one of the biggest and it's 58
owned by america if you didn't know that
so
what are we doing we're actually loading
giving our wealth in debt because we
have to repay them
with interest even though the interest
rate's low little streams make big
rivers
as anyone who's been to um you know
waitaki have been through there the
tributaries make big rivers those people
want to own our debt we can take a
direct loan from the reserve bank
the it's no one adrian nor knows they
all know
and we saw recently what they did during
covert they borrowed money
lots and lots and lots of it and the and
and the
and the reserve bank can do the same for
local bodies but what we do have is a
local
body funding agency which works the same
way we just go along to the
the big markets and we and people bet
for our
for our our um money we all you all know
that
and if you don't know you should know
because you know that's your
responsibility
because our rates don't really cover
that and you've you've had us
going to be paying 21 approximately
rate increase increase over the next
five years so if you've got you're
paying
2 000 a year that's going up to about
400 that's a lot of money there's a lot
of poverty
and what are the constraints on anyone
reaching their capital value
is poverty and you see i've been talking
to lots of people in this town because
i've not been working
for the last year and uh it's given me
an opportunity to talk to people
and it's interesting that valerie
mentioned the the uh
the fact that people who've got
disabilities um
are restricted and you're planning to
block off some of the streets
well i've had a broken ankle this year
and it's been very interesting
having to haul yourself around when
you're not so young
it's you know we all have to um we have
to think about
not so much those who are um able-bodied
but
some of us aren't um spring chickens
anymore and you've got to think
of that so largely what i'm saying you
mentioned about the river
sorry the three waters tim you said that
you've sold off or not you sold off
you're going to be
giving to the government because
apparently they've given the local
bodies a bribe of about something like
500 million dollars
which is a sort of gagging clause which
basically says
that you're going to go along with a
mandate to privatize our water
already they're putting fluoride in it
and whether you're not aware of it
whether you're wearing it or not of it
or not out of 195
countries new zealand is one of eleven
that that fluoridates more than
half of the water these are unelected
people they're wanting to say
they've got no commitment to us we're
committed to this we come here most of
us are rate payers i'm sure we are
and and if we haven't got [ __ ] up a
commitment to this too dunga y way we've
certainly got commitment
because we you wouldn't have taken this
role unless you were committed
now they wanted to fluoridate and um
privatize our water throughout the
country
so who's going to have ownership and
who's going to have management well
already we've lost most of our
of our dairy factories to to china
and i see no i have no confidence
that more and more of our staff will
we'll be paying
our mokapuna will be paying
an ongoing amount of money
to the mukapuna of the super duper rich
throughout the world
it's time you guys woke up there is
another way we don't have to
bow down to the idea that you have to
borrow everything
now some of your ideas are wonderful
however
the constraints on it are where you're
borrowing it from and who you're loading
the debt on to
and it's certainly not the maori way
thank you for your submission may i ask
how you feel about intergenerational
funding rather than
um ratepayers of now paying for
everything in one lump sum but spreading
that cost you're not actually paying for
it and it doesn't even include what
you're not even including the gst
which is 15 which is taken out and it's
not even included in this
and it doesn't nothing is included in
here but we are paying it to
inter intergenerational funding
is fine but why should we be funding the
wealthy my question
was around intergenerational funding and
whether or not you felt that way yeah
well i understand the question but
what i'm i'm saying is that we've heard
what you had to say about the
intricacies of
where finance comes from but i was yes
so yes there is a certain amount but not
to the level
that that we are being dictated to by
people who are selling off uh you see
one of our major assets tim
was the water the water
you know drains and all that we're going
to sell that they've already it's
already happened in whakatani but
they've sold it to
a chinese company no our our mokopuna
will not be happy
if we load the ownership actually we're
giving ownership away it's like a that's
literally what we're doing
if if the debt is owned by others and
our children are paying i don't like
that
not a bit okay thank you councillors any
other questions
if not we appreciate the uh the
submission and the passion with which
you've
presented this afternoon thank you very
much counselors we've got a quick
turnaround
uh we've got a workshop if we could make
our way to the drawing room too
sweet will only be half an hour that'll
be a slightly reduced lunch break
our first submitter is ready to go at 1
20 if we can be all in
you